welcome everybody to the utilities and
roading committee meeting it the way I
make a register account so on Tuesday
the 21st of July I just like to call for
apologies please thank you Mike conflict
for interest you barely got any
conflicts of interests well now do the
confirmation of the minutes it's on page
9 to 16 that sort of minutes on Tuesday
the 19th of May someone like to move
that these minutes be a true encrypt
record
thank you Thank You councillor Williams
and council I keep thinking all those a
favor PCI against carry thank you now
anything that you wish to meet us
arising from the minutes
[Music]
we've got no deputations or
presentations do so we'll move on to 5.1
what just page 17 to 424 and this is :
good afternoon Collin in Hawaii and
Kelley is one so this report is on the
submission of three water safety plans
one as a resubmission of a planner has
been submitted before but wasn't
approved twice so it's the third
submission for the Waikiki Beach what a
safety plan one is a five-year in your
what a safety plan so all water safety
plans need to be renewed at least year
three five years so that's for the cust
water supply and the other one is due to
an upgrade on the scheme which is the
Gary Muir water supply so evasive the
scheme significantly changes within the
five year period you need to update the
water safety plan to reflect the changes
in the supply so as with no previous
meetings that's becoming increasingly
challenging to get what a safety plans
accepted to the point where it's
it's yeah all water suppliers have have
really struggled to get them accepted in
the last about six to twelve months so
we in order to try to overcome this we
are putting a lot more work and to
gathering even evidence on each of our
suppliers to demonstrate safety some of
the examples of improvements we've made
under Waikiki Beach plain since the last
submission is we've done a lot more work
on the leak detection analysis on that
scheme so carry directive leak detection
across the whole scheme and included
evidence to demonstrate that the the
lack of leaks on the scheme in that case
and we've also done a lot of work with
any quick planning team on analyzing
burst history analysis of pipes which
has we didn't condition assessment data
so that was another area where we've
been asked for more evidence was on how
how can we justify the conclusion that
the pipes are in good condition so we've
we've put a lot of work into looking at
past performance of pipes to justify the
condition scores we've given them and
also at the last council meeting we got
the hygiene code of practice adopted
which was addressing another area of
concern where they had asked for more
evidence of practices that are
undertaken wind carrying out work on the
water supplies to give Assessors more
confidence that it's done safely and
hygienic Lee so after gathering all the
evidence on each of the schemes we go
through a risk assessment process which
is we take into account all the data
we've collected and we assess the risks
both as though we had no preventative
measures in place and then we list what
preventative measures we have and in
reassess the risks taking those into
account and then these criteria given to
us that that tells us how to define
whether a risk is acceptable or
unacceptable so on Waikiki Beach we
concluded that there were no
unacceptable risks for that supply
for caste we had one unacceptable risk
which was around the condition of the
reservoirs but we have an improvement
project to address that identified as
well which is the renewal of the heat
works and under gary mere supply we had
no unacceptable risks but we did have
there was no electable risks in normal
operation but there were there was an
improvement project identified in terms
of estrogen resilience and redundancy
regarding the need for a second well
because this is the only scheme that
doesn't have any backup well with the
exception of points road but their point
throughout the planners to change that
as well so from a resiliency redundancy
point of view there wasn't seen as I was
seeing that that we need an improvement
but we still have concluded that overall
a normal operation is no unacceptable
risks so obviously that's our assessment
and we submit that to the Assessors and
then they decide whether or not they
agree with us and that's the most
challenging part of it but I think we
have put a lot of work in these cases to
come to those conclusions so the the
only other point to note is that there's
a couple more upcoming submission Saudia
Hoka what a safety plan is do for a
five-year renewal in October of this
year in what in Pegasus was was assist
and not approved in March of this year
so we need to resubmit it as well so I'm
happy to take any questions on any of
those plans
oh it's gone and the question is this
it's a very detailed report of God is
this required moving forward for audit
yes we think it is we've all the water
safety plans have always been quite
comprehensive
I think they we are being we learn with
what kuku Beach that that what we'd
provided wasn't deemed to be enough so
say yes we do think that we need to go
to this level to to try to satisfy the
Assessors and we've looked at other
suppliers water safety plans that
haven't been approved
like crusher City Council for example
India very thorough plans as well so it
is it does seem to be the norm now to go
to the 16 councillor Stewart just a
question I'm unsure whether because it's
referred to I think later on the agenda
about the leakage from these schemes is
that part of the plane that you're put
into I used to nature plan we as the
leakages one of the factors that we see
thank you so last time we had a report
on leakage school-wide cuckoo which was
different 2017 it was over the sorry yes
I'm getting to it last time we hit a
report in 2017 the leakage from while
cuckoo was over the military level of
goal of 22 percent of that was 27
percent and what is it now I think it
said about 17 percent so we the yeah we
have appended an assessment to our water
safety plan and the when we first
assisted during night flow monitoring it
was figure you see it about twenty seven
percent and then we when we did the
detailed in our analysis
their contractor who did that work
identified a few issues most of them
were actually private leaks and the most
substantial one seemed to be a cistern
and headed urinals in the campground
which actually had a very high flow and
they were just flowing continuously so
it wasn't an issue with the public
system but when we alluded to Kemp
granted there and I think you're in
lockdown they just said well we'll just
turn it off until we get effects because
no one's using it anyway and we that
seemed to coincide with the night flows
dropping quite significantly so at some
I showed a couple of things partly there
um the on small schemes a very small
thing can when you don't have much night
flow anyway can be quite significant and
can can change the leakage on the scheme
by about 10 percent just by having a
little thing change unless there are
other things changing in the meantime as
well that we didn't know about but yeah
and there was a couple of other leaks
that were found that we fixed but they
were considered to be pretty minor so I
don't know you know we didn't we
couldn't see a difference from the day
before we fixed it to the day after and
the urinal system seemed to be the thing
that made a bigger difference that we
could tell
and we also yeah we did do with some
other properties where it was noted that
there is a head um private
leaks or they might have been using
water when no one was home like at a
washing machine going so we've written
those people leaders to say that you may
or may not have a leak but please
investigate these things and some of
them have come back to us and said no
particular properties as well so often
when you assess leakage by night flow
you're you're making assumptions about
the amount of genuine use at night but
um if there's private leaks above that
sort of a lower threshold you can end up
overestimating leakage because you
assumed genuine use might as leaks when
it may not be
the days of 2017 at we had a 90 91 %
linkage so when that comes up for
renewal I expect that we need to tackle
it
yep I can talk more about leek anyone
else yes that's Redmond thanks :
I just wondered um what's the holdup
with the walk would in pegasus water
safety plan it'll have a bigger
population than why Kaku cast will Gary
Amir I guess initially we were when we
submitted Waikiki Beach at the Indo 2019
and also would in Pegasus around that
time we were expecting to see an
approved crusher city council plan in
the meantime which would help give some
kind of precedent for what an approved
plan looks like and we never saw that
like that there has an event rated year
so I guess we were partly waiting
because that we were expecting that to
happen and then when it when it hasn't
happened we've just um focused on
getting Waikiki Beach back it first
because we got a letter requesting us to
do that indeed also the other two came
up for renewal in the meantime so there
was no particular hold office just more
just waiting for some kind of precedent
because it does feel like if you had to
just keep submitting plans over and over
again and keep having them file until
we're president has decided upon can be
a waste of resources so it would be
useful to get an approved plan and then
use that as the basis for the next of
the plan but Sir you know that it's
looking like that's not going to be the
position we're in we're just going to
have to do a beast and submit it back
anyway are there any rights of appeal
when your cleaners turn down there's
there's someone you can appeal to higher
up you can formally lodge a disagreement
with the decision we haven't opted to do
that we've just tried to address the
so phrased but I guess ultimately that's
where they couldn't get to a universal
supplier um I think we prefer to try to
work with someone if we can this further
today we are also working with other
councils nationally we're not aware of
any water safety plans being approved
across New Zealand that includes three
from Wellington water and eight from
water care that have not been approved
yet water New Zealand have recently
released a questionnaire to all councils
trying to gain information about their
status of their water supply plans and
their intention is to write a letter to
the Ministry of Health actually asking
for some effectively some clear
direction in terms of where this is
heating because it's not acceptable to
actually be in the position we are for
would in pegasus with water safety plans
being approved and even though we get an
adequacy report effectively they're
being rejected so at a national level
there is some pressure being put on the
Ministry of Health to actually give a
clear direction whether that actually be
some type of Tim pre-approval or whether
it's actually speeding up the process
and the reason for the temporary
approval is that there is a perception
that currently drinking water Assessors
are waiting for the new regulator to
come into full effect to then approve
all the safety plans but if that's the
case we need to have some kind of
interim type measure because currently
what cookie beach in would in pegasus
expired water safety plans what are the
consequences that they
operating under expired plans it's a
question that we have informally asked
our drinking water Assessors what is the
best approach we should be taking should
we be operating under the previously
approved but now expired water safety
plan or should we actually be operating
under the new updated water safety plan
that's not yet approved so we have had a
an official response back regarding that
effectively some of the questions that
would in new zealand has put together or
along those lines in terms of has
anybody nationally got approval to say
okay well you haven't got an approved
water safety plan
but he is documentation that we're not
going to take any enforcement action as
a result of not having an approved plan
so we haven't formally asked questions
of our drinking water Assessors
regarding that and we don't expect them
to impose anything on us the strongest
steer that we've actually had was the
letter that we got from the Canterbury
District Health Board regarding the
status of the WA kuku Beach water supply
asking for an update on it and when it
would be submitted and that's where we
gave the undertaking that we would
resubmit it by the 29th of July hence
this water safety plan coming through we
haven't yet had a letter for wood in
Pegasus but we are expecting we will get
one
do you have a question yes right the
leakage isleye range means ABCD if
you've got a seventeen percent leakage
like we talked about with where does
that fit under ABCD yeah it's not a
direct correlation because the reason
that engineers in particular don't like
percentages is because you can get your
percentage down but just by opening up
all your fire hydrants on the scheme so
it doesn't mean the pipe works in better
or worse condition is just a ratio of
you know night flow to peak ordinaire to
the average flow so the infrastructure
leakage index is intended to be a
measure of the actual condition of the
pipe work so it takes into account the
pressure that you're operating it the
length of mains the number of
connections on the mains and then looks
at what your minimum flow is but taking
all those into account so and it doesn't
matter how much you use on peak days or
not it's just assessing for this amount
of pipe work and that's pretty sure how
much is that leaking and as and enters
that a reasonable amount for their
amount of pipe work and so for Waikiki
Beach the 17 percent equates to a B it's
when it was at 27 percent it was the C
but it's yeah if it was a different
pressure or a different link to pipe it
it wouldn't necessarily you know they
don't always line up for different
schemes
right someone likes you can thank you
yes I just think for a comprehensive
report and well done again thank you
okay just like to just say very
impressed with this report it's very
well done I've actually have mentioned
it to your seat just to say how how well
it's been presented congratulations
yes thank you
right well I'll move it then all those
in favor please say aye
against carried and thank you very much
right we're going to move on then on to
page 425 to 437 this is the proposed
changes to the three waters level of
service so once again Colin and Kelly
and have we got Kevon no it's fine we're
okay well briefed on the wastewater
stuff right so the purpose of this
report is to update the utilities and
rating committee into the level of
service review that's been completed and
also to request the utilities rolling
recommendation to council to include
these updated measures into the draft
long term plan just to explain the
different measures which are probably
familiar the mandatory measures add
those that are seat by the DIA so they
see what we have to measure but we can
opt what our target is said so that's
what we've been revising as if we found
a reason to revise the target and then
there's the elective performance
measures and these are ones that we seat
and we report on at each scheme within
the activity management plans the
measures have generally been modified
either for clarity accuracy or ease of
reporting rather than to actually make a
meaningful change to the service that
someone would notice that they're
receiving and we also took the
philosophy of we wanted to make sure we
only had
performance measures that if we didn't
meet them we would intend to do
something about it rather than in the
past um there are some examples of a
performance measure we would see well we
don't meet this measure but it doesn't
really matter for these reasons so I
think it was more I think the process
should be you have a performance measure
and you know if you don't meet it you
introduce a project and make sure you do
meet it or if you don't agree with the
fact that you should meet it then you
should change the performance measure so
the example of that type of change was
aesthetic compliance of all water
supplies so aesthetic compliance as I'm
not a house vector and one of the things
that comes under STD compliance as pH
and the Waikiki Beach scheme is one
example where pH can be about six point
nine which is less than seven but an
assessment had been done in the past to
say essentially that has no consequence
on the safety of the water so we've
never had an intention to address that
so we shouldn't continually fail on the
performance measure there so that some
yeah that's just one example of the
logic we went through with this process
and the other ones are generally more
along the lines of just making the way
that we report it trying to make that
easier to understand and meaningful so I
won't talk through the individual
measures because there's quite a lot of
tweaks that we've done but we're happy
to answer questions on specific ones
that people may have picked up on new
questions this comes Judd on leakage
again I see that you want to include the
less than 22 percent across the whole
network I'm back in 2007 we had schemes
that 22% I don't know the number of
schemes in my heat I know that they were
when we last looked it was
about 26% but I think the way that we
can make quite good improvements on
there is not on spending lots of money
on fixing pipes and things like that but
actually better understanding night use
on restrictive schemes in particular
because the UM
was with leakage either you can meet it
your free single property into a total
flow balance and we don't we don't have
universal measuring so that would be a
huge cost commitment to do that or you
can look at your night flows and there's
guidance you don't sit out on how you
should take your minimum flow at night
what a portion of that is genuine night
use and then the rest that must be
leakage so that team is to work
reasonably well on on demand schemes
although you know as we talked about
before on a scheme like what kuku Beach
it's quite small one or two little
private issues can can can be quite
sensitive to that but on restricted
schemes it's more challenging we're over
strict as a design that they're supposed
to open at night even when people aren't
using water to keep filling the tanks so
there's not there's no guidance or
published all that we can find from
anyone else on how to use the night flow
method for restricted schemes but also
there's no real alternative yeah a
alternative of flow metering and doing a
complete water balance is also very
expensive so we're just telling some
work with a new water engineer to look
at having loggers on metres that we
could move around build up a database of
actual genuine night use unrestricted
schemes and that would likely just give
us data to justify increasing the amount
of assumed genuine not used based on
actual data we've collected and that
would in turn reduce the the leakage on
all those schemes so I think through
actually understanding I would use a lot
better the leakage will come down
without actually flexing a single leak
that's just we need to find a way to
understand
would he use a lot better than what we
currently do to more accurately report
on it so we wait until we've completed
that work in the meantime we're kind of
a little bit you know we know we're over
reporting but we don't yet have the data
to justify a new methodology until we
can go through their work ourselves
Kelly's just shown me the table of
schemes that are over or under 22
percent so the it's basically all
they're fully restricted schemes
mandible inside Summerhill listed and
oxford one and two are all 22 percent
that was over the winter of 20
it was over 20 18 19 financial years ago
on that period so that was over 20 18 19
and the range across the district was
from about 8 percent on Pegasus to about
60% on some of the restrictive schemes
but again that we really just need to
understand not use bitter because I'm we
just today we've been looking at data on
the inside scheme because it's sort of a
case study of a restrict this game where
we do there's a low enough number of
connections we could put meters on most
of them and look at that data so it
won't be cost-effective to do there on
the biggest schemes but we just thought
gonna test the theory on the over
estimating and that they are first car
that went from about 58 percent to about
30 percent leakage so we have without
fixing a leak just by getting a bit
better data so I think we just need to
find a cost-effective way to get good
data on the others
the desired leakage rate there from 2017
yes that change did you say 26 I just
seem very similar 26 machine yeah yeah
yeah there definitely is a bit of a
margin for error we are we don't do a
full flow balance so yep that's but we
can also you know there might be other
ways we can address that as well like
we've been talking today also about
pressure management so we could for
example lower the pressure when demand
is low and increase it when it's high
and that would that wouldn't help with
their ili because the ili just looks at
for a given pressure how much is it
leaking in a few the equation knows if
you lower pressure you should get this
leakage but it helps with the percentage
so if it won't help prove our pipes and
better or worse condition than what it
is for water safety plans and things but
it will help in terms of that percentage
of water lost which is also important
yeah there's quite a few months I've had
a report about 3/4 Russian and it
triggered and updated the water
conservation strategy which became a
much bigger task and I intended because
it so yeah I yeah I think though my
planners get to this 15 to you an hour
thank you yes Williams and you might be
doing this already but yeah is it
worthwhile seeing litres Cove and
schools and any places about you rhinos
to hit them cheap yep yeah so good we we
have been starting to think about that
but not actually getting it in place yet
but I think education so we do we do do
community education on on water use but
I think we could probably do it in a
slightly more targeted way
- for particular things like that like
we did on that topic we've got about a
hundred and fourteen properties that are
meted that we do actively read as
they're kind of representative sample
and one of those was or something quite
a few of those were schools and one of
them one of those schools we noticed
particularly high use and again it was
urinals at that school and we talked to
the school and they were in the process
of upgrading dear I'm doing an upgrade
at the school anyway in address there so
we have at one school reduced it but we
and we have looked at data at other
schools that were seems a lot more
reasonable but um yeah I think we
there's more work we could do in terms
of public education and thinking how we
target questioners have we cheek their
own supplies of urine also public toilet
surrender yep yes we I haven't been
involved in that and we should I also I
don't go to lots of our public toilets
but I don't usually see urinals in them
but I'm sure we have some urinals in the
district so yeah we definitely should
make sure our buildings are thank you my
question is plays with the restricted
supplies do you take into account stock
drinking water through the evening and
people watering their gardens and things
like that at nighttime so like I said
all taken into your account for your
percentage it's basically the
methodology that city and the water loss
guidelines as it's very basic it's just
to look at the minimum flow at night in
winter and assume a low level of genuine
youth so it doesn't it doesn't think
about all those different things that
you might find on a restricted scheme
and not on others should take into
account people who irrigate the gardens
at night but again it's just that any
refrig figure that was come up with in
2019 when the guidelines were published
so I'm and I can't I don't know you know
the person who came up with the
guidelines how much research they did
into there we're just using it as the
document in New Zealand that's accepted
as the way to do it but I'm getting
around out or I think we'll definitely
help was there yes I'm always nervous of
performance measures that say a hundred
percent so I just wanted to query the
ones that you've amended I did like the
wording but I just wanted to query the
one about investigating flooding in in
different areas you've got it as a
hundred percent if there are areas that
we are aware that we cannot solve that
are too difficult to solve or have been
investigated before
how will you cover it under that
performance measure
I think the key to that is the wording
that has been added into the performance
measure itself where we talked about
that a hundred percent are investigated
and we had justified measures
implemented to improve the situation
so what we're actually committing to
with 100 percent is that 100 percent of
them will be investigated but it's only
where it's justified that we will
actually go and do meters I mean true to
that is there going to be some sort of
time frame put in there because
sometimes obviously things are
investigated but then how do you then
have a measure for completing works and
actually looking at a time frame for
them we haven't thought about putting in
a time frame I guess we actually from a
reporting perspective we report this
within a financial year so my
understanding of how would we we would
report on this is that if we have
investigated it in the improvement
measures that are planned in place and
then that would actually be a tick in
the box in terms of that 100 percent
compliance so I'm not I don't think we
would be actually marking ourselves down
we've actually done the investigation
and programmed something but not
actually done the physical works you
someone like to move this report please
well I'll move it and we go from a three
to L thank you once again thank you very
much for this report it's very very full
report and I congratulate you both on
that it's it's well done
okay all those in favor please say aye
against a character thank you thank you
very much appreciate it yes so 438 - 447
thank you this is Greg and Kelly thank
you thank you
the purpose of this report is to provide
an update on the 1st of June 2019 flood
event so as you will recall this was a
significant event that resulted in seven
houses six carriages being flooded and
we had about 40 other service requests
related to flooding on private property
of the 105 service requests that we
received 60 of those were classified as
warranting further investigation type
work and of those 60 investigations 21
of those had been addressed and
completed through the 22 had been
assessed and either new upgrades
identified or have they've been
associated with existing upgrades we
were already planning on doing in the
near 17 that further investigation is
still underway on so 1.5 of the summary
sets out the projects that we have we we
are doing upgrading works and so a
number of those will be familiar to you
in terms of projects that we have
underway that will be constructed either
this financial year or next financial
year in 1.6 sets out the sites where we
are doing through their investigation
work now this those sweats here are
works the further investigation is
effectively we were just going to do
some more CCTV type inspection to
confirm that our existing system
working is we expect it to be working so
we're just checking that there's no
blockages were not aware of we're not
expecting to find anything wrong but
it's just effectively a double check in
some critical areas where we want to
double check that the flooding that
occurred was more related to the amount
of rainfall that occurred rather than
there being any and inadequate
infrastructure so happy to take any
questions it was just one correction
than the report 2.0 page six four point
nine change department to committee
where it sees utilities and roading
Department apologies for their I just
wondered is it possible within our
present network and I know you do have
some alarms on some systems and it comes
back to a central control center but we
there is some valves in this age of
digital systems is it possible to
identify and before these upgrades where
you have sensitive points and like
there's a couple of instances here where
they're aware of bells got stuck and
flip bells
is it possible for some gear to go on
these areas where it will identify that
it's stuck we have done some work in
that area
over the past 12 months we've actually
moved to a more proactive maintenance so
we actually have them on a regular
inspection shedule now so we there's a
requirement it's it's on an annual basis
to go through and actually do a full
condition assessment of the flat gate
and - including taking photographs of
the status of the flat gate so that
occurs on an annual basis so a full
inspection to make sure it's functioning
isn't as intended we also have a
reactive type inspection that has
undertaken so that's when as part of
looking at the weather forecast in the
next three to five days if there is any
significant rainfall that is predicted
we mobilize our maintenance crews to go
out and check our pump stations our
girls our critical sons and now also our
flat gates to make sure that they aren't
blocked in any way and that they are
functioning isn't ended so we don't have
anything like an alarm or a sensor that
actually detects whether it's working or
not
but we have put in measures to make sure
maintenance staff are checking the
condition of the flat gates as part of
those pre-event inspections thank you
two questions following that one being
is this his this checking system
developed to deliver well you've got it
now post June 1st 2019 like you didn't
have it in place and and because I'm
particularly the the velh the flip gate
that blocked on the car canoeing in in
the flooding and cool place and south
carp week I mean that is a problematic
area are you telling me that these
systems are now in place since then and
the second one is how how costly would
have been to put sensors on flipped
bells could you can you do that and
monitor these really problematic areas
the driver for looking at this was
probably actually more than July 2017
event that we had and at that point it
which wasn't is a significant storm
event but during that I mean we actually
had some issues with some flat gates
that we didn't know we actually had so
back then we're vex or since then we've
actually done a detailed order to
actually make sure our s records are up
to date with what flat gates we actually
have the next step for that was
developing a inspection form that now
our water unit has for doing those in
you inspections and that's now linked in
with the amos project that we have
underway for doing more rather than
reactive type maintenance proactive type
maintenance so the it wasn't solely the
1st of June 2019 event that initiated
this it has been ongoing related to
other flood events and it is part of our
overall
mints to our data set and also our
proactive maintenance programs for SS in
terms of the cost to go and put in such
census if if it was at a site like a
pump station site so there was a flat
gate at a pump station site where we
have existing telemetry SCADA system
it's effectively and we've got power to
that site it's effectively there just a
cost of actually you know putting in the
sensor and connecting it into the
existing SCADA system so that would be
relatively modest in terms of scene so
maybe in the order of a thousand dollars
on kissing but it's the site which you
know flat gates in the kiln place
example where we had a flat gate that
didn't work that's on William Street we
would have the challenges of either
getting electricity or solar to that
site giving in a sensor connecting it to
either our SCADA system some here either
by the cellular network or some other
means so that's where the cost would
actually start to ramp up quite
significantly in terms of having an
effective you know electronic sensor for
the status of a flat game not not at the
moment I think if we were in the
situation where we did have a flat gate
that was so critical that we had to have
that level of monitoring over them you
know we would definitely look at it but
because we actually have staff that are
checking these flat gates prior to an
event and they are traveling around
looking at pump stations during the
event you know we are in a position to
respond pretty quickly to address
anything that's not performing as
intended and it is a little bit we do
have a list of hot spots so you know
critical sumps that we know we've had
problems with in the past
you know if we know we've had issues
with flat gates in the past we'll
definitely be checking those during
events as well picked up if you were
going around and looking at it on doing
the first and you know it's clearly
critical I think it is a fair question
to ask and we certainly debrief
during the event and during the debrief
we acknowledge that we had not picked
that up as early as we could have during
that event or responded as quickly as we
could have and we are identified some
breakdowns and our communication line
between our road maintenance contractor
and staff and also the contractors we
had we've actually so we've got the road
maintenance contractors their own staff
water unit staff and we've also got a
contractor who we used to do some live
management of pumps and that didn't work
on the day so I would I you know it'd
feel a lot more confident that now
taking the lessons from this event we
would have responded to that sooner and
I'm pretty sure we've acknowledged that
at the time and I'll still acknowledge
that today so it was a fair question to
ask and we I don't think it would have
made any difference in terms of the
extent of flooding that occurred but it
would have made a difference in terms of
the duration of flooding because we
actually we in turn and deployed pumps
and to cool place to pump that area down
and we end and we could have got those
in earlier in that day to help in that
area
council reitman thanks Kelly and 1.7 you
refer to the Riverside bowling club in
at one point there was one point six and
one point seven that indicates that the
work is predominantly to confirm the
existing reticulation wasn't good
condition and functioning as intended
the Riverside bowling club made a
deputation to the cowboy to a weak
community board twelve months ago the
impression was that the water that baked
up and flooded the grains was the result
of the absence of that sort of non
return valve and that the water was
coming from the street or from somewhere
else I just wondered have you
investigated the cause of the problem
and come up with a solution yes we have
so project delivery unit have done a
detailed investigation of the Riverside
bowling club and had looked at a range
of different issues in potential
solution Thea
we are currently engaging with the
representative from the bowling club one
of the key things that they've
identified is that in the plans for the
stormwater drainage that was submitted
to Council as part of the building
consent they actually had a pump that
was draining the the artificial surface
the the green the site investigations
identified that no pump has actually
been installed at that site in that's
quite key for two reasons one you know
the pump would obviously help with
draining down the green itself but also
the discharge pipe is a smaller diameter
pipe than the upstream pipes leading
into the chamber and presumably because
it's actually going to opera intended
topper
under pressure so we're currently
working with the bowling Cup to
determine why the pump was never
installed and the reason that it's
included under 1.6 is we're not
expecting at this point in time that
council from a drainage perspective is
going to have to provide any funding for
a solution near the solution might
actually be for the bowling club to put
in the pump that was originally planned
as part of the development questions
something like to mean Dacian please a b
c and d thank you thank you
right so that's canceled all right do
you like - nothing dude would you like
to thank you I'll move it then all those
in favor that's to carried thank you
very much and how the truth
okay right we're going to move on now
with portfolios roading counselor
Williams please yeah well I think most
people sort of know what's hitting the
road in seen I'd like a weird out Leah
what's happening with the Southport Road
we've had a week committee they're
investigating what weekend we had when
roading teams come up with a proposal
that it was basically unanimous for the
team that tallest street becomes a bit
of a crossing near and some lights in
some one-way areas around and we
actually think they'll be the safest
option for people crossing the road it
would save some condition on that road
which was going to help a lot of the
year there's only a wee bit of money to
go towards of the stage so it's got long
term plan so then it's probably the
council whether they want to stick up
with a big budget on long term pain to
help Southbrook well which is more
important the sku bridge or CS book I
don't know if we can hear both but but
this particular play and I what was
unanimous near committee we all thought
the tallest street was a very natural
fit myself I I was blown away from
excited that the staff had thought out
of the square and and they've come up a
real good solution with the school
movement and car moving the air so that
helps the cyclists it helps the
pedestrians here it helps the traffic
management around the whole area so and
I think that would be a good thing to
look forward to but there's going to be
some money involved to do it that's see
the biggest problem but it's so yeah
thank you tomorrow with the mere to talk
to eking about the line side drain drain
depending on what it's really called who
knows which is the major drain which
either a tide gate controlled and goes
into the upper carboy and that it
discharges literally tons of sediment
coming off the lower line side road
paddocks on the the north and south side
of line side road and it has been
subject of complaint for the last three
years to the water zone committee and
there's there's been quite a lot of
investigation on our part and the drain
that we are responsible for this council
is responsible for has been cleaned but
it hasn't resolved the issue and it has
come down to a land management issue
essentially the it has stock and
cropping on an area of wetland and so in
between the two councils come up with
some sort of solution because in fact
what it does is negate the efforts that
this council is doing on rehabilitation
of the kayakoy River with this continual
flow of of sediment into it goes goes
into the the type Gators is on just
along from the start of the patient out
path you pass it as you you're going up
so then it's an issue I hope that we
come to some solution about the other
when the stop wanna race issues I I just
note that and I've noted quite a bit
that there is planting people are
planting
then very very close to the saltwater
race and the latest example that
everyone can go past as Springbank honey
on the corner on Oxford in galleries
they have planted natives hired up
against the race we've met
mulch and now they're putting a fence
there any rain and the whole the whole
mulch is going to go straight into thee
into the race my understanding was that
the bylaw in someone will need to
refresh my mind and about it is no
planting within ten meters of the race
is that the case come so what happens to
the other side
this road well if you if you've got the
along for instance Oxford Road if you've
got it hard against on in the road
reserve and wherever that is on the
property boundary in in people are
putting landscaping hold up against it
so what happens when you put mulch and
it washes into the race anyway there's
more of this happening around the
district then I think desirable in the
type of plants that people are putting
in like um canna lilies and which way to
go but here so I'm bringing an issue I
think needs to be addressed in some sort
of fashion through we've got a bottle
that needs to be people need to be
educated get a visit from somebody just
to check out with a complier Thank You
councillor Williams again utilities yeah
I'll just inform everybody a wee bit
about the I think everybody sort of an a
wee bit of knowledge that we're looking
at putting in and solar pair and the
surge complex and ring you earth and
given Sydow whoever we talk to us and
he's put it on hold a wee bit because of
the t y aluminium smelter pair prices
might drop so they couldn't considerably
and affect their proposal of doing it so
then so that's been just he's
negotiating with Meridian and down it's
on a wee bit of the hold at the moment
we know what happens with the water side
everybody knows Gary Muir long last is
up and running and running good and
everybody seems happy and we've got
another meeting with points Road people
tomorrow night which is going to be
tricky meeting that I think we've got
staff and what we can handle it I'd
probably like to put this point again a
pet on the back for a staff member
Colin Roxburgh through this committee
hear of the amount of work time and good
work in putting
into all this type of snare there he's
very conscientious and he's doing a real
good job in my box and I don't praise
many people but for me to do it it means
he's doing a real good job and hope you
like the CEO to look him an email to
them say things from listen committee
for the work he's putting under son he
is putting in a real good job so you
know it seems for me that's all
so as you're all aware we had oh yeah so
I'm his this waste we already meeting on
the 8th of July we've got issues with
regard to recycling fever of the coma so
the conversation is yeah we're gonna
deal with some of those issues obviously
communication is gonna be important so
we're looking at dancing there in
Christchurch there are four people that
awarded the recycling bins in the city
we're hoping that we're gonna you know
pull their expertise yeah yeah some sort
of system whether it's asteroid tech or
whatever I was told me them appearance
on Sunday and they were quite proud of
the fact that they got a tick on the ear
assortment then so it seems to make some
sort of difference having a texture so
the teeth of almost there's a joint
landfill followed by Joint Standing
Committee meeting and Christchurch
though we follow them most of you saw
eugenie sakes announcement with regard
to the levy last week I will point out
there is a little thing in the
announcement which sees current economic
conditions will be considered before
implementation timelines
I can feel later this this year so I got
no debt there's going to be an increase
in the levy but here much and over what
timeframe is it seems to me to be to be
unknown and I'm in with him aware of
some emails going around on how we might
potentially be speeding it yet it
doesn't come into effect until next
financial year and we don't know to what
level that will come into effect so
Kitty's got a pretty hard road trying to
anticipate a few of these things to put
into era LTP when we go into the new
year and start discussing it that's all
from me thank you
counsel me thank you yeah
apologize oh that's right was it
counselor before I was me yes so they
were yes
look just transport update really hit a
really good meeting with the ins ETA CEO
last week while I was in Wellington
that's Nicole Rosie kneeble was joining
me up at rural and provincial so he came
along to the meeting as well in Jim
Palmer not Jim Palmer Jim Harland zoomed
in to their discussion so I raised with
him Prince with who principally concerns
around the bullion safety improvements
program certainly the bypass was on the
discussion but we know where they sit at
the present time but the safety
improvements for the principal
discussion point via took on board by
the way are kept frustrations on the
delay and their project in the lake of
communication clear communication with
the community around raising their
expectations out in the public arena and
and then leaving it for a good year
before there's been any communication we
got this was following the mission with
the Transport Minister not long after
that we got a indication of the
signalization of the crossing and
through wood eanes so that's like likely
to be October with the construction
season but it is did raise still around
the funding of that raised the concern
around the fact that albeit they're
going to go out and do some work now
they've indicated yet the staff member
from NZTA his name that was here the
other day that he's going to be leading
that exercise more I said that we do
want the community board and council
briefed on on that before we go to the
community I think we need to make sure
we're aligned and then space and well
briefed so she'd have been on board I
also raised the cases we are we're not
getting the funding
we have important to us you bridge all
those other meters and she did indicate
to me that perhaps we might want to
consider her a more a lot more lobbying
of the provincial growth fund apparently
councils that have been a bit more
active in the space of lobbying and the
provincial growth space have hit some
good results and she cited Queenstown so
it's on my list to reach out to the
minister's office to find out who we
need to talk to it in the right ear but
with go they came back say no so also I
raised around the ture he we speed
limits in the rudeness of that process
that we've been through end the threat
by one of the staff of legal action I
just thought was appalling so Jim
Harland is going to follow that through
so and also going to look at having a
more regular meeting with Jim Harland
who's the regional relationships manager
here because these projects have ours we
do need to keep an eye on them and make
sure that we've got lines of
communication now staff certainly do
whether the leak that level I see Jim at
greater Christ's huge pub it's with a
different role this is important to our
district so agreed that there will be a
way forward Nicole Nicole are certainly
encouraged by here she's quite
forthright and I think she'll be a
breath of fresh air for NZTA she
certainly took onboard them that they're
not particularly good in the space of
communication and consumer do be sure
so she said watch me with the
performance that we do in the space so
I've given the 12 months well she said
give me 12 months and I agreed on it but
I seen the reality is though I do want
to see some action and the spaces that
we've talked about so it was a good
discussion and I was hit a good hearing
so that's all we can ask for yes you can
ask a question
I'm just wondering will it's worthwhile
reinforcing to the entrants board and
they will know that there's been another
two major accidents on that road and the
last week or so and you know what the
safety side of its and looking it for
that bypass just they will know but just
another reinforcing that you've what do
you mean by past yet because I've been
to I think in the last then week so
that's another now we need to now home
that we're not happy with the safety
aspect and see the in terms of safety
that's their priority yeah bypassed
absolutely but the reality is and and
and and this is a change significant
change in government policy and it gets
on the priority duster it's it's not
likely to happen and I'm being real
about it but we we mustn't give up on
that either so and continue to advocate
for it but I'm being purely real the
ones that I personally I think we need
to be focused on is getting those safety
improvements in the interim the two
major things I think the safety
improvements here I put skew bridge on
that list and and a solution of some
kind we mustn't forget about South Pro
the three major areas that we really do
need to if we're targeting we should be
there in those areas we've got lots of
other priorities but they're ones that I
think we're just going to need to pick a
few and work on those and keep being the
drum on they are and they respect
yes well we'll see
we whilst well I I've noted it as well
but we'll see anyway I don't want to
comment on politics here just another
way question their place through the
right safety can we push through that as
well many angles as we can you know it's
laughs daddy I'm that doesn't hurt so
please let us treat it as well okay or
all the forms that we can raise the
topics of our priorities to be sure
you